[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
differences between the Monster vs
Godzilla and the new -1 Godzilla two
versions of the king of the monsters
that we are expecting to see within a
year's time we shall take a look at
their sizes their overall body design
their face dorsal plates tail legs
personality and all that comparing one
to another so let's get into it firstly
let's start with size the most diverse
G-Man was originally 355 feet or 108
meters tall in his first appearance but
in king of the monsters and onwards he
is 393 feet or 119.8 meters in height
Godzilla minus one on the other hand is
planned to be more in the lines of the
original shower size being not too big
as to make him indifferent to humans
just around the side that would make him
both terrifying and also able to
interact with people on a more
believable level we have estimated his
size on our previous video to be around
60 meters or roughly 200 feet in height
half the size of the monster verse Titan
now to the overall body let's start with
coloration and scales the most of us
version has grayish black tone overall
with slight brownish elements and
highlights his scales are more
crocodilian in design with repetitive
scale structure and a set of gills on
his neck he also has osteaderms that
seem to be symmetrical in placement and
appearance in both sides of his body the
minus one however has a more rough
texture his coloration is dark brown and
black with grayish overtones his scales
and osteaderms seem to be uneven all
over the place like pebbles bringing a
more Eldritch theme to the game they
look rougher and seems to Overlay a
message of a nuclear charring with a
rocky Stone appearance he also doesn't
seem to possess any signs of visible
gills
now what about their head and face the
most of us Godzilla has a square shaped
face and a white neck the eyes are small
and have golden yellow color while the
teeth are smaller and less neatly
arranged they just seem to come out from
the scales the nostrils are separate and
positioned on opposite sides of the
snout further enhancing his reptile-like
appearance
-1 however has the most scary Sinister
look his face is more like the heisei
slash Stan Winston's failed design and
final wars hybrid with a more curved
snout and having a feline look his eyes
are bright yellow in color with visible
pupils and a set of rows of osteadones
lying at the top of his head like the
original design they look like braids
his teeth are well defined looking like
swords that jut out from both the upper
and lower Jaws
now let's go to the dorsal plates in the
2014 Godzilla design the dorsal plays on
his back are smaller compared to the
Japanese adaptations however they still
maintain the maple leaf shape although
in a straighter sharper look resulting
in a mode Jagged appearance Like a
Chainsaw the 2019 version has a
different approach instead of a jacket
and straight look this iteration
features more protrusions on his back
and also the Maple Leaves seem to look
more noticeable notably the three
prominent Central dorsal plates in the
middle of its back retain the same shape
as The Originals minus ones most
prominent difference from most other
Godzillas are his dorsal blades they do
not have the traditional Maple Leaf
although certain elements of it are
still seen his dorsal plates look like
gigantic Thorns or sword tips emerging
from a central stem they are done so to
give the Godzilla a horrific appearance
with everything in his body screaming
out death and destruction compared to
the flatter and mode side look of the
most diverse plates
now let's take a look at their arms and
feet
most of us feet are larger and more
robots compared to previous iterations
with a distinct dinosaur sauropod-like
appearance they feature three toes with
thick rounded claws providing stability
and emphasizing his powerful presence as
for his arms they are relatively short
in proportion to his body reflecting the
Aquatic origins of the character these
arms are muscular but not as prominently
visible as his massive legs both hands
and feet feature black claws
minus one Godzilla also have massive
thick legs which seem to have drawn
inspiration from singular points
Godzilla's design they are also dinosaur
in appearance but look more
theropod-like rather than a sorepat-ish
feet of the monster verse instead of
three big toe claws he has four of them
with long black claws his arms are small
in size relative to his feet but the
hands possess eagle-like Talons meant
for Devastation and killing
now what about the tail most of us tail
is pretty long it started as being very
thick stemming out from the back of the
Torso and gradually thinning out to a
sharp end the entire tail is lined with
triangular plates and osteaderms each of
them still a viable storage of nuclear
power he uses his tail for both combat
against other Titans and also for
swimming around the world's oceans minus
one's Tales also start out as being very
thick and robust but the entire length
of it seems to be more of the same
thickness although gradually becoming
smaller to the extremity it appears to
be tube-like and shape with the thorny
scales and plates on it the end of the
tail also differs in that it is round
instead of being pointy like the monster
versus one
now strangely let's take a look at his
underbelly well the inner parts of every
Godzilla meaning his belly and chest all
differ from one another as well the most
diverse version has a big belly with a
muscular chest and the scales seem to
form some sort of blades right on the
middle of the breast section several of
these make Godzilla look like he got abs
cool
but -1 has the same rough uneven scaly
texture even in his undersides although
there seems to be several row
segmentations near his pelvic region his
chest on the other hand looked like two
massive pegs which have third degree
burns and cluttered with rock but that's
just my observation what do you guys
think
since we know nothing about minus one's
Powers we shall take a look at the
personalities of differences well in the
most of us he has depicted Godzilla as a
solitary and enigmatic creature he
possesses a strong sense of territory
asserting dominance over his domain and
defending it fiercely from threats
Godzilla's Behavior suggests a sense of
balance and order in the natural world
his presence helps restore ecological
equilibrium maintaining a delicate
balance in the earth's ecosystem he is
classified as a benevolent protected
Titan BY Monarch as for the minus one
Godzilla we do not know much about his
overall personality but we can say that
he will be a force of Destruction not a
kaju that has a soft feeling for
Humanity since he will be portrayed as a
monster that brings back the horror
elements he will no doubt be Humanity's
enemy and therefore will be seen as an
evil entity
so those are the differences between the
most diverse and the minus one Godzillas
I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe to push us through the
algorithm of YouTube but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
and new videos like this on this channel
take care fam